[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute was süßes und
zwar haben hamm sah mich dass in den
flitterwochen der bahn wenn der türkei
wir haben jeden tag gegessen ja in den
flitterwochen nimmt man ja immer so ein
bisschen zu und wir haben dem alle ehre
gemacht ja wir haben eigentlich jeden
tag kuchen und desserts vergessen und
einfach besonders beliebt bei uns nicht
das magnolia dass er das ist in der
türkei richtig beliebt aber auch in
anderen ländern als ich weiß auch gar
nicht aus welchem land es kommt er nicht
zu sein
das ist nämlich eine schicht ist er das
kann man machen wie man will aber ganz
beliebt sind zum beispiel kekse pudding
und erdbeeren und weil wir jetzt gerade
erdbeersaison haben habe ich mir gedacht
das passt jetzt richtig gut auch zu
ramadan reihe haben so ein kleines
bisher sachen staat und die zutaten die
da drüben stehen hat wissen auch sehr
überschaubar und die gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an
für unsere pudding creme wird milch
benötigt außerdem schlagsahne mail
vanille extrakt und zucker und ein ei
außerdem benötigen die nüsse und
butterkekse und natürlich unsere
leckeren frischen erdbeeren so jetzt
beginnen wir natürlich mit dem pudding
und der super easy leute ihr müsst alle
zutaten rein in den topf als ich gefragt
habe warum habe ich in die milch auf
getrennt hätte keinen großen behältern
musste das deshalb so machen
es gibt es einfach alles in einen topf
aber den herren noch nicht einschalten
[Musik]
und jetzt das ganze einmal klümpchen
frei verrühren und dann wird erst der
herd eingeschaltet
[Musik]
und jetzt müsst ihr ständig umrühren
damit der topfboden auch nicht anbrennt
und das ganze wird jetzt aufgekocht
danach liegt der pudding schön ein
domizil die höchste stufe
ihr könnt das auch langsam aufkochen
lassen um sicher zu gehen dass nichts
anbrennen und danach einfach sofort vom
herd ziehen
[Musik]
jetzt muss der pudding nur noch
ausdampfen dafür gebe ich ihnen eine
andere schüsse und decken an der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie ab
[Musik]
den pudding können wir erst weiter
verarbeiten wenn der hand warm ist also
er muss jetzt nicht komplett aus können
aber er darf auch nicht so heiß sein
aber wir können es ja schon um die kekse
kümmern
und hier könnt ihr vollkommen
butterkekse normalen schoko butterkekse
ganz wie ihr möchtet ich nehme mal das
was ich glaube da habe und mit dem
müssen zusammen richtig schöne
kombination und das max ich habe erst
mal richtig schön sein
[Musik]
die masse wäre somit auch vorbereitet
gebe ich jetzt ganz kurz hier rein und
was für ebenfalls vorbereiten können
sind die erdbeeren die habe ich schon
gewaschen und etwas trocken getupft und
jetzt werden die also einige werden
halbiert und andere werden nur
durchgeschnitten für die deko oben drauf
aber das zeige ich euch hier zum besten
für die erdbeeren im glas einfach das
grüne wegschneiden und für obendrauf
lasst das grüne doch gerne dran das
sieht man richtig schön aus das ist so
ein schönes farbspiel finde ich und dann
schneidet ihr sie ganz einfach in
scheiben aber der obere teil der muss
dran bleiben also den nicht komplett
durchschneiden
[Musik]
selbst habe ich die eltern auch
vorbereitet und jetzt können sich
entspannt zurücklehnen
natürlich bisschen die küche so lange
aufräumen und warten bis der pudding
abkühlt und dann einfach nur schichten
ja mit den flitterwochen feeling nach
hause bringen genau so und jetzt fürs
schichten braucht ihr einfach nur noch
gläser hübsche gläser und ich nehme
jetzt hier meine doppelwandigen gläser
dass ich dann immer besonders cool aus
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch
handelsübliche gläsern eben alles was
ihr da habt hauptsache man kann es von
außen sehen jetzt nehme ich hier meine
keks masse und gibt es als boden einmal
darauf hin dass klar ist drauf ist es ja
nicht
sollen die jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere
halbierten erdbeeren und geben sie mit
der schnitt seite nach vorne in das glas
rein schön an die seite drücken
als nächstes gehen wir den leckeren
pudding rhein und main sid richtig die
vanille stückchen brennen
schaut mal hier und das ist so praktisch
dass die jetzt noch lauwarm ist dann ist
er nämlich nicht so fest und man kann
richtig schön mit dem löffel in das glas
geben
[Musik]
und auf die pudding schicht kommt jetzt
noch mal eine schicht die kamera etwas
dünner sein
von unseren butter keksen und dann
einfach die erdbeer darüber
[Musik]
und was immer gut zu desserts mit
erdbeeren passt und vor allem mit creme
sind natürlich pistazien einfach wegen
dem geschmack und auch wegen dem
kontrast durch die farbe und diesen was
ganz besonderes denn ich habe dafür
gekämpft dass diese pistazien aus
gaziantep aus der türkei bei uns im shop
verfügbar sind
ich habe jetzt hier 100 gramm packungen
überlegen noch ob 200 gramm packung
nehmen sollen das interesse so groß ist
und da könnte uns erkennt man die
kommentare schreiben
das interesse bei euch ist dann haben
sie und ich wir richten uns eigentlich
immer noch aus und die habe ich jetzt
noch grob und gibst du darüber
[Musik]
ihr könnt die pistazien auch malen aber
ich finde ich hier sind sie ganz einfach
hübsche aus und es gebe ich jetzt noch
dazu und ihr glaubt gar nicht könnte das
jetzt so verdrücken
bleibt das so hunger drauf es ist echt
eine herausforderung fast und so ein
leckeres tcr bisher zurück zu bereiten
ich kann schon gar nicht mehr reden also
sieht eigentlich eigentlich zu schön um
zu essen aus viel zu schön um zu essen
angeht bin ich voll durch einen dann
nochmal jetzt will ich voll
durcheinander
es sieht es sieht einfach viel zu schön
aus uns zu vernaschen aber egal ist was
für dieses zitat für die bekommen dann
ja das kriegen wir mit sicherheit und
jetzt muss das ganze in den kühlschrank
für circa zwei bis drei stunden die
creme soll richtig schön kalt sein
ja also zwei stunden das soll halt
richtig schön kalt sein
yahoo war also wir zumindest und das gas
umfasst jetzt zum beispiel zwei 120
millimeter und das rezept ist ausgelegt
für sechs dieser gläser ich kann nicht
gerne alles nochmal in der infobox
schreiben die zutaten und mengenangaben
sowieso und alles was ich benutzt habe
gerne auch und wir hoffen dass sie
wieder flitterwochen feeling bekommen
heute abend wenn wir das probieren und
ist wir waren in den flitterwochen sich
kennst ja ganz gezählt das video ist ja
eh zu ende wird dran bleiben wir doch
jetzt dran
also wir waren eher in kalkar das ist in
der nähe von antalya und da hatten wir
so eine richtig schöne private
ferienwohnung mit infinity pool mit
blick auf mehr
das war richtig schön nur einfach nicht
gestimmt dass das wetter es war richtig
kalt habe mir dann vor ort noch mal zwei
drei akten in kauf weil ich ja keine mit
dabei hatte auch vor ärgerlich und dann
hat man weil die chrysanthemen nach
essen wir zu meiner familie damit haben
sie auch mal die kennen die er in
deutschland zwar noch nicht gesehen hat
oder nach istanbul
und dann sind wir doch nach istanbul
geflogen so wollte danach ist ja wohl
der bürger kommt ich war da auch noch
nie und das einfach richtig schön und da
haben wir fast jeden abend dieses
dessert gegessen war richtig lecker es
gab es auch mit kastanien und mit orio
war auch richtig lecker
das kann ich ja auch mal ab er schreibt
mir jetzt wenn ihr noch dran was ich
hoffe ihr schreibt mir jetzt hier in die
kommentare
welches magnolia das ist ja eher als
nächstes sehen möchtest man variiert er
dann auch die creme und so weiter
schreibt mir noch gerne meine kommentare
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten video wieder einschalten
vergiss nicht ein bäumchen nach oben da
zu lassen und einen kommentar zu
schreiben
hallo haben wir doch schon ihr habt mich
sagen ja und die werke aktiven bekommt
immer mit wenn ein video kommen ja okay
bis dahin ihr lieben schützen
[Musik]